plus hors murs du ballet le sénat comme
vous ne l'avez jamais entendue
[Musique]
bonjour chers visiteurs
bienvenue au jardin du luxembourg un
écrin de verdure au coeur de la capitale
[Musique]
autour de nous il ya des marronniers des
érables de cappadoce des parodies de
pertes la fontaine médicis percent les
amoureux qui ont fait de ses abords un
lieu de rendez vous galant à l'ombre des
grands arbres
voici quatre siècles que la fontaine
réside dans les jardins du luxembourg
une bien longue histoire qui débute au
xviie siècle
[Musique]
nous sommes en 1610 henri iv roi de
france vient de mourir devenue régente
marie de médicis veut recréer à paris
les palets florentin de son enfance elle
rêve de grottes de fontaine de bassan de
terrasse avec des jeux d'eau et pour
créer ce lieu féerique elle s'adresse
aux jardiniers jacques boisseaux
approchez vous venez observer d'un peu
plus près selon bassin bordée de
bégonias
avez vous reconnu sur le fronton de la
fontaine les armes de la france et celle
des médicis
juste en dessous une statue de marbre
blanc représente le mythe d'assisses et
galatée une scène racontée par ovide
dans ses métamorphoses
galatée une 9 et a61 jeune berger
s'enlacent tendrement
aveuglée par l'amour ils n'ont pas vu
juste au dessus d'eux polyphème un
cyclope autre est monstrueux jaloux de
leur idylle celui ci écrase son rival
sous un rocher galatée hurle elle
suppliait du de transformer en fleuve le
sens de son amant pour qu'ils puissent
gagner la mer
galatée est entendue voilà donc le sens
du pauvre berger qui s'écoule lentement
le long des marches sous les yeux de
diane la déesse de la chasse et d'un
faune
[Musique]
si vous aimez la mythologie fait le tour
du bassin y laissez vous surprendre par
la food and lead a plus discrète presque
dissimulés par les arbres qui
l'entourent elle tourne le dos à celle
d'assister galatée
cette fonte elles représentent les juba
de leda et de son amant jupiter
métamorphosé en signe selon la légende
jupiter a pris la forme d'un oiseau pour
séduire la jeune femme et de leur union
naîtront quatre personnages dont les
noms ne vous sont peut être pas inconnu
castor pollux hélène et clytemnestre
avec de tels parure la fontaine est
resplendissante en 1889 elle est classée
monument historique
cela coulait de source n'est ce pas
[Musique]
au fil des années la splendeur de la
fontaine c'était un peu estompée c'est
pourquoi le sénat a pris la décision de
la restaurer pendant deux ans une équipe
de restaurateurs d'électriciens de maçon
d'horticulteurs nous préparer pauli
assainies ils ont rénové la statue de
bronze de polyphème en atelier et
déplacé ce cyclope qui mesurent presque
3 mètres et pèse deux tonnes n'a pas été
une mince affaire ils ont également
restaurer le statut d'assisté de galatée
du faune et de diane de la corniche aux
escaliers d'eau en passant par
l'évacuation des eaux pluviales
rien n'a échappé au travail minutieux de
tous ces artisans
est désormais depuis la rue de médicis
dans le silence de la nuit tombée vous
pouvez contempler jusqu'à une heure du
matin la fontaine de l'eda mise en
valeur par un tout nouvel éclairage
restauré en bélier sublimer la fontaine
médicis peut à nouveau recueillir les
murmures des amoureux
[Musique]